a king of New York City's skate scene an
80s teen Queen destined for fame and an
animal who left pro sports for Japanese
TV they've been gone for years but these
actors haven't been forgotten Rob knox's
portrayal of the obnoxious Marcus belby
and Harry Potter and the Half-Blood
Prince Sans has his first and only major
part in a motion picture belby is a
Ravenclaw student and a candidate for
the slug Club a meeting of Hogwarts best
and brightest pupils hosted by Professor
Horace Slughorn Knox played the part of
belby with a sweet vulnerability before
he could begin filming his plan to role
in Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
part 1 Knox died after an early morning
fight outside the Metro Bar in southeast
London Knox had just wrapped his scenes
for the Half-Blood Prince he was stabbed
after stepping in to thwart an attack on
his younger brother Jaime in the weeks
leading up to the stabbing his killer
Carl Bishop at altercations with Knox
and his friends Bishop wound up with a
life sentence in prison Rob Knox died on
May 20 24 2008 at the age of 18. the
Marvel movie fans Powers Booth is a
familiar face the actor portrayed Gideon
Malik a villainous former leader of
Hydra in the Avengers and Agents of
Shield but the character actor enjoyed a
lengthy film and television career long
before his MCU role after years spent
perfecting its Craft on the stage booth
made his film debut in 1980s cruising
the 80s saw Booth deliver strong
performances in films like Red Dawn and
the Emerald Forest through four decades
as an actor Powers Booth appeared in
over 60 films and television shows my
full attention is at your disposal for
his last film was 2014's Sin City a Dame
to kill for the follow-up to Robert
Rodriguez and Frank Miller's 2005 hit
Sin City he died at the age of 68 on May
14 2017 from pancreatic cancer
Matthew Garber played the younger Banks
child Michael in the original Mary
Poppins and was only eight years old
when he took the role the eldest of two
boys Garba began acting with the
encouragement of Shakespearean actor
rydo trees garba's film debut came in
Disney's the three lives of Thomasina
when casting directors fell in love with
the boy's fun exuberant personality
after Mary Poppins Gaba starred in a
final Disney film
1967's the snowmobile in 1976 a 21 year
old Garber caught hepatitis while
traveling through India although he
returned to the United Kingdom for
treatment it was too late and the
disease had affected his pancreas on
June 13 1977 Matthew Garber died of
complications from hepatitis Alexis
Arquette was born into Hollywood royalty
her father Luis Arquette was an actor
and director and her mother Brenda Marty
Nowak was an actor and activist who
taught acting classes and ran a theater
her siblings Rosanna Patricia and David
Arquette were each carve a successful
path for themselves to acting stardom at
12 years old Alexis took the plunge into
professional acting starring in a music
video for the song She's a Beauty by The
Tubes born Roberts Arquette Alexis knew
she was transgender from a young age our
kids had sex reassignment surgery in
2006 and supported other celebrities
like Chaz Bono who wanted to do the same
I'm happy to speak about it to anyone
even if it's somebody who's who I don't
know but I certainly I have boundaries
limits in the 1980s she broke ground for
transgender youth at 19 she played a
trans sex worker in the 1989 film Last
Exit to Brooklyn our cat starred in over
40 films to her prolific career although
most were small independent movies in
the 1990s Arquette appeared in
supporting roles in She's All That The
Wedding Singer and Pulp Fiction after
Contracting HIV in 1987 Arquette went
through long periods of poor health in
2013 she decided to live once more as a
man butzar gets increasing Health
decline could not be reversed on
September 11 2016 at 47 Alexis arcare to
died after being placed in a medically
induced coma due to HIV complications
the official cause of death was cardiac
arrest
George Gaines enjoyed a storied acting
career before emigrating to the U.S in
his 30s Gaines served in World War II as
a member of the royal Netherlands Navy
he trained that the legendary Actors
Studio in New York City in the 1950s and
began his career on Broadway Gaines
appeared in classic 1970s series like
the Six Million Dollar Man and Colombo
often playing minor supporting roles he
acted in over 10 films in the 1980s
including Tootsie dead men don't wear
plaid and police academy George gained
warmed kids hearts in his long-lasting
television portrayal of Henry warnermont
a kindly fostered out of Punky on the
NBC series Punky Brewster Gaines married
his wife television actor Alan Anne
McClary in 1953 and they remained
together until his death Gaines made his
last film appearance alongside Ashton
Kutcher and Brittany Murphy in 2003's
just married on February 15 2016 at the
well-seasoned age of 98 Gaines died of
natural causes
Theresa Saldana made her film debut in
1978's I want to hold your hand and Rose
to fame with her role in The Academy
award-winning film Raging Bull Saldana
played Lenora the Mata a sister-in-law
of protagonist Jake LaMotta Saldana
quickly garnered recognition for her
acting Talent later scoring a role in
defiance which also starred 80 Star John
Michael Vincent and playing Rachel
Scully on the CBS series sir Commish big
house on the hill that's not the
American dream
with the American dream
damn straight on March 15 1982 Arthur
Richard Jackson a Scottish Drifter who
had been stalking Saldana approach the
actor in front of her home and stabbed
her with a hunting knife I did call the
police on March 8th and they said that
they couldn't send anyone out because
there wasn't enough manpower the actor
survived the violent attack but was left
with severe wounds and spent four months
in the hospital Jackson served over a
decade in prison but continued to
threaten Saldana from his jail cell
after her attack Saldana founded the
advocacy group victims for victims she
lobbied Congress to help establish
California's 1990 anti-stalking law and
the national 1994 driver's privacy
protection act Sol Donna wrote A Memoir
about her experiences called Beyond
Survival and played herself in the
television film victims for victims the
Teresa Saldana story soldana continued
to act on television until 2003 and on
the big screen through 2004 on June 6
2016 seen at the age of 61 Saldana died
of pneumonia Ron Lester is probably best
known for playing Billy Bob a fun-loving
offensive guard on the West Canaan Texas
high school football team in 1999's
Varsity Blues hey Mark you're skinny ass
let's roll
a Georgia native Leicester began his
acting career in commercials and
appeared in a music video for the
country band Little Texas he left
Georgia for the sunny skies of Los
Angeles to pursue acting and stand-up
comedy full time from 1997 to 2002
Lester appeared in five films including
good burger and Not Another Teen Movie
he made his last film appearance as
Roger Hardwick in 2015's racing Legacy a
film he also wrote and directed
Leicester underwent gastric bypass
surgery in 2000 dropping over 300 pounds
from his heavy frame but in 2015 he
began to experience severe liver and
kidney problems in which he never
recovered at the beginning of June 2016
he began Hospice Care Ron Lester died of
kidney and liver failure on June 17
2016. he was 45 years old
for over half a century David Huddleston
graced our Cinemas and small screens his
acting career showed impressive range
and his character roles endeared him to
audiences but Huddleston wasn't a
household name you may know David
Huddleston from films like Blazing
Saddles and the 1971 made for TV movie
Brian's Song as well as his portrayal of
the titular character and The Big
Lebowski on television huddleston's
roles range from Gilmore Girls where he
portrayed the Beloved eccentric mayor to
Harry Potter to Bewitched where he
played several characters Huddleston
grew up in post-crape depression rural
Virginia and fell in love with acting
and his youth his first film appearance
came via an uncredited role in 1963's
all the way home his last movie was
2014's locker 13 on August 2nd 2016
David Huddleston died at 85 due to heart
and kidney disease
okay
okay who gets the privilege another
respected character actor John Polito
co-starred with David Huddleston and The
Big Lebowski where he played Pi defino
chances are you've seen many of Polito's
movie turns as a mobster or cop two of
the actors Mainstay characters his
outstanding film resume includes four
other Cohen Brothers films Barton Fink
the HUD sucker proxy the man who wasn't
there and the Epic Miller's Crossing he
also played Detective Steve crisetti on
the NBC television show homicide life on
the street from 1993 to 1994. Polito
studied theater Villanova University by
the time he was 30 he began regularly
working in Hollywood Productions
although his roles were often Typecast
her lito uniquely crafted each character
in a time when many actors remained
closeted Polito was openly gay and
married his longtime partner Daryl
Armbruster on October 16 2015. on
September 1st 2016 less than a year
after his wedding pulitzo died due to
multiple myeloma he was 65. Brad
Leslie's name may have more recognition
with hardcore Baseball fans and with
moviegoers known as the animal for his
Brawn Heights and in-game theatrics a
six foot six inch Leslie played Major
League Baseball from 1982 to 1985.
Leslie moved to Japan in 1986 where he
played for two seasons before retiring
from baseball and becoming a Japanese
television personality his Larger than
Life stature and Persona made him a fun
favorite on the Japanese game show
Takeshi's Castle in the 1990s Leslie
began appearing in Hollywood films as
well he was best known for the roles
that reflected aspects of his personal
life like Niven in Mr baseball and John
blackout Gatling in Little Big League
Leslie began to experience declining
Health in the 2010s after his kidneys
failed he was placed on dialysis and
moved into a nursing home on April 28
2013 Brad Leslie suffered a heart attack
and died at 54. Alberta Watson spent her
early adulthood carving a career in
Canadian television and movie
productions but soon plunged into
Hollywood work and landed meaty Parts in
a variety of film and television shows I
don't tolerate any weaknesses
it's not how I work in the critically
acclaimed transgender musical Hedwig and
the Angry Inch Watson played the loving
mother of Hansel Hedwig Schmidt her dog
turn as the incestuous mother and David
O Russell's directorial debut Spanking
the Monkey stood as one of her favorite
roles she also appeared in the suite
Hereafter and hackers Watson's last film
role was 2009's Helen she ended her TV
career in 2012 with the recurring role
of Senator Madeleine Pierce on the keita
Watson was first diagnosed with lymphoma
in 1998 and died of complications from
cancer on March 21 2015 at age 60.
throughout her Elementary School years
Amanda Peterson starred in local theater
Productions in her hometown of Greeley
Colorado it didn't take long for
Peterson to score an agent and after
guest appearances on his 80s shows like
silver spoons and father Murphy Peterson
starred on the big screen in explorers
alongside River Phoenix and Ethan Hawke
it was Peterson's role as a popular
cheerleader Cindy Mancini in 1986's
Can't Buy Me Love had endeared her to
audiences although she appeared destined
for meteoric fame Peterson's blazing
Hollywood career seemed to fizzle by
1994. work's not really my thing she
retired from acting and returned to life
in Colorado he just then struggled to
navigate through her post-celebrity life
she turned to drugs and soon developed a
severe addiction after several arrests
Peterson attempted to regain her life
friends told The Denver Post that in her
later days she spoke of getting back
into acting she dreamed of opening a
studio for young aspiring actors Amanda
Peterson died of an accidental morphine
overdose on July 2015 five days shorter
for 44th birthday
Anderson's name may not ring a bell but
by the early 80s she had appeared in a
plethora of commercials after several TV
guest appearances Anderson landed the
starring role in 1982's Savannah Smiles
playing Savannah Driscoll a young
runaway who befriends two convex
Anderson received a young artist award
nomination for her work and appeared to
be a star on the rise but acting roles
dried up by the time she reached her
teenage years her last film appearance
came in 1987's too much Bridget Anderson
died on May 18 1997 of an opioid
overdose at 21 years old
in the early 1990s Christopher Lee
pettiere's classic good looks and
natural Talent helped him land multiple
television appearances on shows like a
Doogie Howser MD and Star Trek the Next
Generation his early film roles included
Point Break and Sandman but petier is
best known for his performance as a
Middle Brother Zach Crandall in the 1989
Cole classic Don't Tell Mom the
Babysitter's Dead the black comedy
initially tanked at the box office and
was panned by critics but eventually
gained a large cult following a TA
earned teen heartthrob status and steady
work due to his role including Parts in
the ABC series The Young Riders and the
1996 indie film Boys on April 12 2000
petier died from an accidental drug
overdose he was 24 years old
Ashley Aston Moore is best known for her
role as Chrissy in 1995's now and then
playing the young counterpart to Rita
Wilson's adult character and flashback
scenes Chrissy
Ambitions before you dry up like a prune
what's that supposed to mean no one then
stood out as a female driven film full
of Rich character development painting a
realistic portrait of the tween years
and becoming a favorite shared Movie
experience for many young girls like so
many child actors Moore began appearing
in commercials when she was barely out
of diapers but her acting Korea began to
fade after her turn and now and then she
made her last screen appearance in 1997
in an episode of Touched by an Angel
more opted out of the Hollywood Life and
moved to Vancouver British Columbia
Canada according to friends she
developed an addiction to heroin while
still in her teens which continued
through her adulthood at the age of 26
Ashley Aston Moore died of an accidental
heroin overdose on December 10 2007.
growing up in the projects of the East
Village in New York City Harold Hunter
developed a passion for skateboarding he
spent most of his time skating in city
parks where he quickly gained attention
from skate apparel companies Hunter was
featured in Thrasher magazine in 1989
and sponsored by Zoo York he snagged
modeling jobs for prominent fashion
companies like Tommy Hilfiger Hunter
symbolized the New York City skate kids
culture and Remains the reigning King of
the city's skate parks while into
adulthood after starring as Harold and
kids Hunter appeared in an episode of
New York Undercover and held minor roles
in independent films on February 17 2006
Harold Hunter died at the age of 31 of
myocardial infarction a heart attack
induced by cocaine best known for his
roles as a woefully named half sack on
the effects drama Sons of Anarchy and
chilly on fox says the OC Johnny Lewis
left the Hollywood Community reeling in
shock on September 26 2012. he killed 81
year old Kathy Davis a longtime friend
to artist and the landlady of the
writer's Villa Lewis who had previously
rented a suite from Davis in 2009 had
just moved back into the home after
killing Davis Lewis felt his death from
The Villa's roof in the months leading
up to his death Lewis had exhibited
strange violent behavior and had spent
time in Twin Towers correctional
facility for committing several acts of
unprovoked violence he experienced
constant legal and mental health issues
between 2009 and his death at age 28 in
2012.
Justin Pierce dropped out of high school
and became part of the skateboarding
scene in New York City in the early 90s
trouble with drugs and criminal activity
peppered appears 16 years but her role
in the 1995 film kids would provide an
escape photographer turned director
Larry Clark discovered the 19 year old
skateboarding in Washington Square Park
with his friends a fledgling director
offered Pierce's first starring film
role as obnoxious Casper the best friend
of kids protagonist Telly we're asking
commercial film resonated with teenage
audiences and critics alike and PS won
an independent Spirit award for his role
he continued to connect with viewers
through his authentic portrayal of
troubled teens going on to Starion a
Brother's kiss next Friday and other
independent films unfortunately Pierce's
life issues followed him to Hollywood
while in Las Vegas to promote next
Friday the then 25 year old actor took
his own life on July 10 2000.
best known for playing Jeffrey Barone on
Everybody Loves Raymond Sawyer Sweden
was cast with his twin brother Sullivan
at just 23 months old though the Twins
were cast together on the Ray Romano
vehicle Sawyer went on to land a film
role without his brother in 2002 the
actor played a young Frank McCluskey in
Frank McCluskey CI the film didn't fare
well at the box office and was panned by
critics but Sawyer proved he could act
on the Silver Screen Sawyer grew up in
the Limelight and by all accounts was a
funny and kind kid sadly things came to
an abrupt end when he took his own life
on April 23 2015 at just 19 years old if
you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please dial or text
988 to speak with the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline you could also seek
help by visiting 988 lifeline.org
foreign